the USA men's basketball team won the
gold medal yeah they are they won the
gold by completely destroying Serbia who
lost to the USA 99 to 66 yeah now yeah
[Music]
believe me believe me we would love to
show you highlights of the game but for
legal reasons we are not allowed to show
or air Olympics footage you just can't
do it what I can do is show you a live
reenactment of the USA basketball
highlights against Serbia right here in
our studio let's do that now
[Applause]
sort of how it went there you go again
certainly out of touch
survey how to really difficult
it is just
[Applause]
you'd be in better shape it's just
we have a great show tonight ladies and
gentlemen you know turnout Frankie's in
the program
[Applause]
from the nut clips original series
orange is the new black Daniele Brooks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just it's just wrong the Serbians I have
to say they're taking it really well
comedian Noah garden Schwartz is on the
show
[Applause]
we're back Jimmy took it away
[Applause]
you